Okay. So today we continue the topic of
secret societies. Last class we
discussed how they come into power.
Today where we will look at where they
come from and what they believe. Okay.
So to understand secret societies I
first need to explain to you the history
of religion in the western world. So in
the western world there have been three
major stages of religious development
and again I will oversimplify
for the purpose of clarity. Okay. So
this is a simplified version of the
history. So the three major stages of
religion develop of religious
development in the western world are the
mother goddess,
uh polytheism
and monotheism.
Polytheism means many gods. You believe
in many gods. Monotheism means one god
that only one god exists. So the mother
goddess civilization
um came about because of agriculture
and in an agricultural
world you have two problems. The first
problem is to make sure that your crops
are healthy and you can harvest them in
time. The second problem is to give
birth to have as many children as
possible to work the fields. Okay. So
these are the two problems and because
of that a religion developed in order to
facilitate facilitate both called the
mother goddess civilization. So at the
center of this religion is the womb.
The woman's womb is considered a divine
portal from the spirit world into our
world.
It's almost like a cave
right in which the spirit world can come
out and manifest itself in our world. So
the center of this religion is the womb
of the woman and as such the woman are
control.
What's really important is to understand
that in this world everything is
interconnected, harmonized, balanced
together. So the womb is the center of
this world. But then you have the stars.
Okay, the stars.
And of course this gives rise to
astrology.
Astrology
is a study of the movement of the stars
in order to understand its its impact on
our world. Right? Then you have of
course
um
the crops
Right? So in an ideal world, all three
are aligned together. By setting the
stars, you know when to best plant the
crops and when to best have children.
And in this world again, it is the woman
who are in control. They have a high
status in society because they believe
that women are direct representatives of
the mother goddess who rules the world.
Usually in this society the mother
goddess is represented as a bird. Okay,
a bird.
Why? Because if you think about it, if
you study all the animals in nature,
it's a bird that has dominion over the
sky. And if life comes from the sky, it
makes sense that the mother goddess must
be a bird of some sort.
But the mother goddess is also paired
with a bowl. Okay? A bowl. Why? Because
a bowl is a symbol of verility
and energy.
You cannot you cannot get pregnant
as a woman by yourself. You need a man
to do it for you. Okay? So the bird and
the bull are the two symbols of worship
in this world.
Now this world is very strange from our
perspective because there's no property.
Everything belongs to everyone.
There's no hierarchy. Everyone is the
same. And there's no such thing as
um
as sex by yourself. Okay. So sex is
actually a community act. So they have
these rituals um called fertility cults,
fertility cults in which
they have sex together. In fact, many
men will have sex with one woman. And it
makes sense because as a woman, you want
to have the best DNA. You have the you
want to have the best sperm, right? You
don't know who's going to have the best
sperm. So just have sex with everyone
and whoever has the best sperm will give
it to you. Okay? So that's the mother
goddess civilization.
Then we switch to polytheism.
So why do we make the switch? The answer
is war.
For the first time in human history, as
populations increase, there's now
struggle for resources.
And what's the most important resource
in this world? Do you guys know?
>> The most important resource is
woman, right? Females. Because it's
females that give birth. And that's the
And so with war, we have a new concept
called property.
In order to get men to fight wars, you
have to give them something as reward,
right? So they get to have a woman, a
wife. And now this wife belongs to them
and only them. So in this world what
happens is that you now have property
hierarchy and marriage and the role of
the woman decreases and the role of the
man increases.
Okay. At the same time what's happening
is that these different societies in
order to fight wars they have a god.
Okay. And when they go to war, they it's
like the gods are going to war. And if
you lose the war, what it means is that
your god is inferior to their god. So
now you have a hierarchy of gods. So to
maintain peace, what happens is that if
you lose the war, you omit that your god
is weaker than their god and you you now
must obey their god,
right? And this is what we call the
pantheon.
So remember in the Greek pantheon, Zeus
is at the top and you have Apollo,
Aries, Aphrodite. Okay? Everyone else is
a lower god. But before they were
separate gods and in a series of wars,
the people who believe Zeus is the best
god won out against the other gods. And
as a result, the other gods became
Zeus's children. Yes. Do you have a
question?
>> Um why does uh like the man the men's
are fight for women but womens don't
fight for men? like the women's don't um
fight for the men. So why?
>> Okay. Okay. So the question um is why do
men go to war and why don't women go to
war? Okay. So that's a really good
question. Okay. So let me explain to you
very slowly. So in this world the women
are in control,
right? So women have all the status. But
over time as populations increase you
have a you have young men who have no
families and these young men are
discarded from the societies because of
lack of resources. So these young men
have a problem. They need to find wives
in order to survive. So these young men
start to raid other societies in order
to capture women. Hey, do you
understand? So in this society, it's
never young women who are discarded
because they pro they have value to
their society. It's always young men who
are discarded and as a result these
young men become like wolves. Okay, they
become like a wolf path who then go and
pillage other villages and that's how
you start and that's and that's how you
have the origin of war. Okay, does that
make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, so now you have this pantheon of
gods. Okay, which leads to polytheism.
Then we make the switch from polytheism
to monotheism. Why? Because now you have
a new idea called empire,
specifically the Roman Empire. And they
introduce a new religion called
Christianity, which is the first
monotheistic religion in the world.
There's a lot of debate um as to what
was the first montheistic religion. Some
people say Zorashianism, some people say
Judaism. I will I will show you in this
class later on that actually the first
religion that was monistic is
Christianity. Okay.
So the difference between between this
society which is a society based on war
is you still there's a lot of humans but
humans are still the most precious
resource. Therefore, it is not in your
best interest to kill everyone. But we
have when you have an empire like the
Roman Empire, you don't have to worry
about killing other people. In fact, you
can go and destroy entire societies,
which is what the Romans did. And you
can now as an empire enforce impose your
reality, your god on everyone else.
That's how you have monotheism. Does
that make sense? All right. So, let me
explain that. What I'm going to show you
now is how the world view our
understanding of the world changes over
time.
Okay. So in the
mother goddess
civilization there are two things about
their world that's very different from
our world. Okay. So the first major
difference and this is this is really
important for you guys to remember is
they understood that mind led to matter.
Mind leads to matter.
But in our world we believe that it's
matter
that led to mind. Right? Do you
understand? So in science class you're
taught we have a brain. Then the brain
because of synatic connections creates
the mind. Okay. So, it's matter that
leads to mind.
Um, even though we're taught this, if
you think about it, it actually doesn't
make any sense because how does our
small little brain, how is it able to do
so much processing, which is the mind,
right? How how are we able to imagine?
How are we able to dream? It's really
confusing for us. And quite honestly, if
you talk to the very best
neuroscientists in the world, they their
response will always be don't ask this
question. Okay? It's never like we don't
know. It's always like don't ask this
question. Okay? This question is
forbidden to ask in neuroscience.
But so throughout most of human history,
we believe that was mind that led to
matter. That it's the mind that creates
the brain in order to understand the
world. Okay? that makes a lot more sense
than mind
uh matter leads to mind. Okay. Okay. So
that's the first major difference.
Throughout most of human history, most
societies believe that it was the mind
that creates the brain. The second major
difference is that this is a
metaphorical
world. In other words, they spoke using
metaphors. They understood the world
through metaphors. Today we live in a
literal world.
Okay, what's the difference? Well, the
difference is this.
Let's just say that you and I fight.
Well, we would say that okay, what
happened was that um I became angry, the
emotion overwhelmed me, and then I hit
him, then he got angry, then he hit me
back. Okay, this is a literal
interpretation, but back then the
metaphorical understanding was that
anger is a god who seized me and who
propelled me into the fight and then
anger unleashed the god of vengeance who
fought back by seizing the other person
to fight me back. Okay, so we believed
for most of of human history that we
were controlled by forces outside our
control. Now today you may believe that
the literal world makes more sense. But
if you think about it from the
perspective of human thought, okay, how
do you understand the world? How do you
um interpret what goes on in the world?
The metaphorical understanding is
actually much more useful. And that's
why and I and I know this is hard for
you guys to understand. back then they
were much more creative than we are
today. Okay?
And also the things that they were able
to do
are beyond our imagination. So for
example, we've never really figured out
how the Egyptians create the pyramids.
Okay, for our explanation is aliens did
it because their mind is beyond our
imagination. Okay. So that's the that
shows you the switch. Now when we go to
the polytheistic um world, this system
still continues but they add more
elements to make it more complex. Okay.
So the first element is
they believe that we are controlled by
gods. We are the play things of gods.
Now, what's really important to
understand is that these gods, Zeus,
Apollo, Aries, they're no different from
mortals. The only difference is they
just live forever. Okay? So, for
example, if you're a king,
what do you like to do? Well, you like
to go around and chase young girls
around. Okay? What does Zeus do all day?
What does Apollo do all day? These gods
all they do is go around and chase young
girls around. Okay? So there's actually
no difference.
Above the gods are the older gods.
Fortune,
fate. So the belief was that even though
these are gods, they're still controlled
by forces beyond their understanding
understanding like fortune and fate.
What mattered in this world was not to
be good. What mattered in this world is
to be lucky. Okay? to be fortunate
because that showed you that that the
gods favored you. And the last element,
the most important element is the
unwritten
and immutable
laws
of the universe.
Okay? So a concept like justice.
So think of gravity, how gravity gives
structure to the universe, right? Well,
back then they believe the same thing
where at the at the most fundamental
level there were concepts that existed
like justice
and if you you could have to favor the
gods and you could be very lucky but if
you did things that were unjust then
eventually you'd be punished for it
because you're breaking the structure of
the universe. Okay. So this was the
polyphysic worldview. Now when you go to
the monistic worldview
all this changes because now you have a
new concept that never existed in human
history before called one true god.
And this changes everything. Okay?
Because before as you can see humans
thought in a very complex sophisticated
diverse imaginative way about the world.
But now with the with the advent of
Christianity it's only one true god. And
as such, you have three new concepts
that become dominant in this world.
These these concepts have existed
before, but now they're dominant. The
first concept is the idea of truth.
Okay? If there's one true God, then
there must be one truth to the universe.
And so when we move towards the truth,
that is good, right? But when we move
towards but when we move away from the
truth that is evil.
So now you have a new concept called
evil that that that didn't really exist
before.
Okay. You did good things because in
this world it was to your advantage.
Now in this world if you defy God that
is evil.
Okay. And now with truth and evil you
have a new concept called the
individual.
Before in this world what mattered was
your family, your community, your
society, the people around you. Now with
the advent of one true God, the
community and family doesn't matter.
What matter is your loyalty, your faith
in the one true God. So you can actually
step outside your community and just do
what you believe is right as long as you
have faith in the one true God.
All right? Okay. So
this three concepts truth, evil,
individual are important for you to
remember because they underpin
modernity. These three concepts once
they grow to a certain extent they will
create modernity. the world we live in.
Okay, our world is controlled by these
three forces. Now, what's important for
us to understand is these three concepts
are beyond the human intuition.
You cannot logically by yourself deduce
or come up with these three concepts.
This world of the mon goddess, it's
intuitive. Okay, this polytheistic world
is also intuitive. But the Christian
world now is counterintuitive.
Okay.
So as a result um for montheism to
triumph because it is so counter
counterintuitive it must now destroy the
politistic world.
Okay. So the Romans
spent a lot of time taking centuries and
centuries to destroy the politistic
world. But the thing is this,
you can never ever kill an idea.
The idea if it is being suppressed just
goes underground. Okay? So remember here
in the mother god civilization the main
instrument of religious worship are
fertility cults run by women. Well now
that war has come and men have taken
over from women. What happened is that
the woman went underground to create new
religious organizations called mystery
schools.
And mystery schools
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to maintain the best knowledge
and traditions of the mother civiliz the
mother god of civilization.
Okay. Especially the fact that we come
from the mind.
We created the universe through our
imagination. Okay, that's the main
secret that they're trying to maintain.
These mystery schools become extremely
popular among the elite because they
offer great sex. Okay, the elite join
these mystery clubs as sex clubs.
Basically,
um remember in this civilization what
matter is the womb. So they develop all
sorts of like secret sexual uh
techniques to please the woman be to
make the woman feel association harmony
with the uh uh universe. In this world
the mother goddess sex is a mechanism to
communicate with the universe to
discover the secrets of the universe.
And so they maintain these rituals in
the mystery schools. And the most
powerful people will participate in
these mystery schools. They're called
mystery schools not because they're
secret, but because
everyone is sworn to secrecy. So if you
um ever divulge what actually goes on in
these mystery schools, you'll be
punished by death. Okay? You'll be
executed by the members. But with the
advent of Christianity,
these missionary schools now are a
threat to the empire. Okay? Because
these missionary schools are where the
elite, the local elite hang out. So now
what happens is now they become secret
societies.
Okay? That's where they come from.
Secret societies are an attempt to
maintain the secrets of the universe
against the advent of Christianity and
empire.
And secret societies have been around
for a long long time. You may have heard
of Sunni secret societies like the
Knights Templars, Rosian,
illum, the illuminati, the Freemasons.
Okay, they're all very powerful. They're
still around. Yes, I understand that.
But what I'm saying is there are a lot
more secret societies that we do not
know about and who've been around for
much longer. Okay? But they're all
trying to maintain the secret of the
universe which is that mind leads to
matter. That's the great secret of the
universe. And this is something that
we've always believed and always known.
But with the advent of Christianity,
this has been become suppressed over
time.
All right.
So any questions before I move on? Okay.
So now what what I will do is I'm I'm
going to explain to you Christianity
and I'll explain to you what these
secret societies believe. Okay. I' I've
already explained to you where they come
from. But now what I will do is explain
to you what they actually believe about
the universe.
Okay.
So what I'm going to do is first thing
I'm going to do is explain to you what
most Christians believe about the
religion. Okay? This is called the
orthodox
or the canonical
perspective.
Okay? So this is what you're taught
officially by the church. Christianity
has many different factions, but they
all believe in a certain interpretation
of the Bible. Okay? Then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you the
apocryphal. Apocryphal apocryphal just
means hidden okay or secret or esoteric
just a secret knowledge that is kept
within these secret societies. All
right. So the orthodox comes from a
reading of the bible. And the bible at
its core is a story of the covenant
between God and humans. Okay. Covenant.
Covenant means contract or
understanding.
So throughout
the Bible,
there are a series of covenants. Okay.
The first covenant is between Adam and
God. So you may have heard of the story
of the Garden of Eden, right? God
creates the universe, then creates the
Garden of Eden where he puts Adam and
Eve. And God says to Adam and Eve, "This
is paradise. You don't have to work.
Just enjoy life. The food is free. The
food is plentiful.
Every day, you'll be happy and free of
um want. You will live forever. But
there's only one thing that you must not
do. And only one thing, okay? Whatever
you do, do not eat from the tree of
knowledge of good and evil. Just don't
do that. and you'll be okay. So, of
course, what do Adam and Eve do? They
eat the stupid fruit. Okay? So, then
what God does is he banishes Adam and
Eve from the Garden of Eden. And now
they're forced to work to to grow food
to feed themselves. Okay? And this leads
to
um society, okay? Development of
society. God looks down from
uh the heavens and sees that humans now
are going to war. They are fighting.
They have private property. And God
says, "I don't want this crap. This is
not why I created humans." Okay? So,
he's like, "You know what? I'm I'm I'm
going to destroy everyone and start
over." But then he sees a human that he
likes named Noah. And this leads to
God saying to Noah, "Build a ship. build
an ark and save yourself because I will
flood the universe. I will destroy the
world. So God God destroys the world and
Noah lives. And then God says to Noah,
you know what? That's kind of silly. I
should destroy the universe. I promise
never ever destroy the world again.
Okay, that is his covenant with Noah.
But God sees that humans are still
wicked and evil. And he says, you know
what? I need to find a man who is good.
And I I need him to grow a nation that
can be the light of the world, that will
be the best example of what it means to
be a good person. So he finds a man
named Abraham. And Abraham, of course,
is the father of a nation called Israel.
And so this is the third covenant.
God says to Abraham, "You and your
children, your
uh grandchildren, your
great-grandchildren are now loyal to me.
I see you as the chosen people, and I
gave you the promised land." Okay,
that's what Israel is, a promised land.
Over time, what happens is that Abraham
and his people, they go off to Egypt.
And in Egypt, they become slaves to the
Pharaoh of Egypt. And then God is like,
"You know what? I should check up on the
Israelites and see how they're doing."
He looks down. He says, "Oops, they're
now slaves to the Pharaoh. So, I need
now to fix this." Okay. So, he appoints
a man named Moses
to free the Israelites from Egypt and
take them back to the promised land.
When Moses does this, God says, "Now,
what you must do is give the Israelites
my law, the Ten Commandments." Okay? The
law. because otherwise I can't trust you
guys to behave.
Okay, so now this is the fourth
covenant.
So now the Israelites are back in the
promised land but again and even though
there's laws, they still
become wicked and they start to worship
false gods. So God punishes them and God
is now looking for a good leader of the
Israelites. And then finally he finds a
person named David who becomes the king
of the Israelites. And God says to
David,
"You are the person I've been looking
for all of eternity. You are the best
example of what it means to be a
faithful follower of me, Yahweh." Okay?
And so this is something called the
Davidic covenant. The Davidic covenant
states that God will always favor Israel
as the chosen nation and the house of
David will rule Israel forever.
Okay, so guys, quick question here. Who
wrote the Bible?
Probably this guy. Okay? Right? If you
have to guess who wrote the Bible,
probably not Moses, probably not
Abraham, probably not Noah, probably not
Adam, probably this guy. Okay? because
he's saying that of these five, okay, I
am the best. I'm the God. I'm the person
that God loves the most. My family will
rule the world because that is God's
will. Okay? Now, of course, that that's
not what happens. Eventually, David has
a son named Solomon. And these two are
considered the two best rulers of
Israel. And this is what we call the
Davidic kingdom. Okay? The Davidic
kingdom, the golden age of Israel. But
after Solomon, the Israelites turned
wicked again. And then God has to punish
them and scatter Israel across the
world. Okay?
And so the last covenant is the arrival
of Jesus.
What Jesus does is that
first of all he reasserts the law of
Moses and and say to the Israelite
people remember Moses and his law
because that's what God wants. Then he
sacrificed himself in order to free the
Israelites of the original sin, right?
Because God's pissed off at people
because people
ate the fruit. That's the original sin.
That's the first crime of disobedience
against God. So by killing himself,
Jesus frees humanity of the original
sin. He redeems humanity.
Okay? The last thing that Jesus does is
he creates a new covenant. Okay? A new
covenant
between humanity and God from now on.
Because Jesus has freed everyone from
the original sin. Everyone can now
be with God. You don't have to be
Israelite. You don't have to follow the
Mosaic law. You don't even have to come
from the family of David. Anyone and
everyone can now
love God and God will love that person
back. Okay? And this of course starts
Christianity.
All right? So this guys is called
Judaism. What the Jews believe. Okay?
And this is all six is what Christians
believe. Christianity,
right? The first five covenants are what
Jews believe to be true. But they do
believe that eventually someone will
return to restore the kingdom of David.
Okay? But not Jesus. Not Jesus. The
Christians believe that Jesus is the
final prophet.
Okay? In fact, Jesus is God himself.
that that's why it's called Christianity
because they believe in Jesus Christ.
So this is the entire history of Judaism
and Christianity what they believe
officially.
Any questions before I move on? Okay.
Now as you can understand if you are a
true Christian or you're a true Jew
there are actually lots of issues with
this understanding. The first issue is
um why did God have to kick us out of
the Garden of Eden? I mean, was eating
our fruit so bad as to banish us from
paradise? Like what was wrong with that
fruit? Okay, that's a great mystery in
the religion. Why did the original sin
happen? And why was God so angry?
Second problem is Noah.
I mean like God destroyed the world
because we were wicked. But after he
destroyed the world, we were still
wicked. So why did God have to destroy
the world in the first place? If he's
God, then she then should he understand
how humans are? That would he understand
that destroying the world would just I
mean it doesn't really do anything.
Okay, so that's kind of strange. The
last problem is Jesus.
Um, who was Jesus and why did he have to
kill himself? Why did God have to send
his only son to die for humanity? Right?
So, if you're new to Christianity,
the very idea of Jesus actually doesn't
make much sense to you. I grew up in the
West. I grew up in a Christian world and
it never made sense to me. Okay? People
told me about how great Jesus was. Like,
okay, the story doesn't make any sense.
So if you're a really smart person,
there are lots of there are lots of
questions
about this interpretation of the Bible
and these are the three major ones.
Okay. So now what I what I will do now
is I'll explain to you what the esoteric
what secret societies believe really
happened.
Okay. So I want to start with Noah. Why
did God destroy the world? The reason
why God destroyed the world is not
because of humans but because of
something else. These people are called
the Nephilim. Nephilim.
Okay. Um also by by the way um if you
guys are interested in learning more
there are two books that are not part of
the Bible but which will give you
insight into the esoteric knowledge.
Okay. The first is called the book of
Enoch. Book of Enoch.
The second is called
the gospel of Thomas.
Okay. All right. So I am using these two
books as sources for my explanation.
Okay. So the Nephe
are
children
of angels and woman. Okay. So what
happened was that um the angels who are
supposed to watch humanity
came down and saw wow these human humans
these females are really beautiful. So
what do they do? Well they have sex with
them right and then what happens they
have lots and lots of children and what
do these children do? These children
enslave humanity. These these people are
called Nephe. Okay so if you if you want
to understand what happened let's do a
thought experiment. Let's just say that
there's this group of superhumans called
the Avengers. You know, Spider-Man, Iron
Man, Captain America, Thor, okay? And
they fight Thanos and they save the
world. And now what do they do? Well,
they're bored. So they start to have
lots and lots of sex. They have lots and
lots of children. And these children now
are like demagogues, right? So what do
they do? Well, they enslave humanity.
But then what do they do? Well, they
start fighting amongst themselves. Okay?
So that's basically what happened. So
God had to destroy the Nephilim because
they are not natural. Angels and humans
are not supposed to have sex with each
other and that this creates a new um
power called the Nephilim. The problem
though is the Nephilim are divine and
therefore they cannot be killed. So you
can get rid of their mortal bodies, but
now they become demons
who live underground and are in the
shadows.
And guess what guys, they're still here
today. So these these two societies,
they believe the Nephilim are real and
they still control the world. The
richest people in the world are actually
Nephilim,
okay? because they've been around for
thousands of years and therefore they're
able to control the development of
humanity. Okay? So they called the
Nephilim. So that's easy to understand.
But now the question then is wait a
minute. Why did Adam eat that app that
fruit and why did Jesus have to kill
himself? Well, now it gets really
complicated. Okay? So now I need I need
to explain to you what the secret
societies believe. Okay? Remember they
believe that mind leads to matter. What
does that mean? Okay, let me explain
what this means. Mind leads to matter.
In the beginning,
the true God is called the Monad.
Okay? The one. So just think think of
this as the core of the universe, the
sun, the divine sun. The monad is so
powerful that when he breathes, okay,
he vibrates divine energy. And over
millions of years, this divine energy
creates new life forms. Okay? So the
first life form are called the diets.
Diets are just peers, okay? Usually male
female that are children of the monad
and they're able by themselves to create
new universes as well. Okay. So the
diets start to emanate, emanate,
emanate, emanate, emanate, emanate.
Okay. So so the entire universe is
vibration. It's vibrational energy. It's
vi it's the breathing of these cosmic
beings. Okay. And over time, over
millions of years, these vibrations
become atoms, which then leads to
matter. Okay, that that's what they mean
by mind leads to matter.
Now, one of these diets named Sophia
decides, you know what? I can be just as
good as the monad. What does the monad
do? The monad is able to propagate by
itself, by himself. He doesn't need to
mate. So Sophie Sophie says, "You know
what? I'm going to produce something by
myself. I'm gonna have a child by myself
to prove I am the monad." Okay. So she
does this and she creates a new being.
Okay? A new being. This is called the
demi urge. There are different names.
We'll call them the dirt demi urge. The
demi urge is a monster, a monstrosity
because it goes against a natural order.
So then Sophia is like, "Oops, I
shouldn't have done that." So So what
does she do? She abandons the
monstrosity. She throws him away and
hides him in a sea of clouds. So, no one
knows he actually exists. Okay? Even the
demiurge doesn't know he exists. The
demiurge does not know about this world,
right? Therefore, he believes that he
must be the one true God capable of
creating new life. So, what does he
create? Us.
Okay? He creates the planet Earth
and then he and then he creates Adam and
Eve.
Okay, that's what a monster would do.
Okay, look at this history. What kind of
god would kick someone out of paradise
for eating a fruit? A monster would do
it. Right? What kind of god would kill a
people for no particular reason? A
monster would do that. Okay. What kind
of God would demand that a that a people
be loyal to that person? A monster.
What kind of God would enforce his will
on a people? A monster. What kind of God
would say to someone, you're the only
person I like, everyone else I hate. A
monster would do that. Okay. So in other
words, the true secret that these secret
societies are trying to keep is the god
we worship today is the false god. It's
the and we are actually in a prison
created by this false god. And that's
who Jesus was. Jesus was a cosmic being
sent by the monad to tell us the truth
about the world. And that's why he died
because the Roman Empire could not allow
people to see the truth. If I told you
the truth, you would know it right away.
You would wake up. Therefore, the truth
tellers must be killed.
Okay? So, that's what these secretists
believe. They believe that the monad
exists and the mind of the monad is what
creates creates the universe.
And Jesus was sent to remind us that
even though we're in a prison, there's
still the monad in you. There's a spark
in you, a divine light in you that you
can activate. And if you activate it,
then you will return to the monad. You
will see the truth for yourself. And
when you die, your soul, which is part
of the monad, will want to return to the
monad and can escape this world. But to
activate this light, you must be a good
person. You must love one another. You
must reject money and materialism and
grades. Okay, grades in school. You must
reject competition. You must reject
material wealth in order to pursue
spiritual happiness.
Okay, that was the message of Jesus.
Now, you can imagine that the powers
that be the Nephe were not like this.
Okay, it's a direct threat to Nephe who
now control the prison created by the
demiurge. It's also a direct threat to
the demiurge and that's why these secret
societies have been over the centuries
been repressed been executed okay been
massacred but they believe that it is
their duty to protect the secret because
only by protecting the secret can
humanity be ultimately saved.
Right?
Does that make sense? Okay. Any qu any
questions?
Right? So you have the official version
which is what you're taught in school,
but now you have the secret version that
is only taught in secret societies.
The other thing about secret societies
that's really important is
they believe that most of us cannot
accept the truth. If I told you this,
you think I'm crazy and report me to the
police. Okay? Therefore, they can only
wait for people to wake up by themselves
and approach them. And if if you
approach them, then they will test you
and then they will reveal the secret of
the universe to you. Okay? And that's
why these secret societies were founded
and that's why they've been so
persistent and so successful over the
centuries, right? So now the question
is, okay, this is a great theory, but
how do we know it's true or not? How do
we know that this is actually what they
really thought? Well, we know because
in poetry,
in literature, the members of the secret
societies have embedded the secret
within the poetry. So, if you're able to
analyze the poetry properly,
you will see for yourself that this is
true. Okay. So what we're going to do is
we will study
today the greatest poem in English
language called paradise lost by John
Milton who was who actually was a member
of the secret societies. Okay.
Any questions be before I um continue.
Okay. We're going to repent loss. Okay.
Are we clear? Any questions? Yeah, there
there's a question here.
>> Um, if all of these are from the false
god, do we have a like truth god? Like,
do we or like it's just a thing?
>> Okay. Yeah. So, in this system, the
monad is a true god.
>> Okay. And the question then is why
doesn't the monad interfere? Why doesn't
the monad stop the demi urge from
imprisoning us and making our lives
hell? And um there are two explanations
for why this is happening. Okay. The
first explanation
is that the monad does not interfere in
material affairs.
Okay. Because the monad is it's all
mind.
And also we have the capacity to reject
this world and return to the monad.
Right? So why would he force us to
um do what we don't want to do? Okay. If
you want to return to him, then you have
the choice to engage in spirituality, to
engage in goodness, to engage in
knowledge, and then you'll be able to
return to him. Okay, that's the first
explanation. Second explanation is that
and this comes from Dante. Okay.
The monad is a force that is eternal,
perfect and immutable. And therefore the
monad has no imagination.
But how do you grow as a being? You grow
through the imagination.
So in order for the monad to continue
continue to grow the monad allowed for
the demiurge to create human beings
because as human beings we are flawed.
We make mistakes we commit evil but by
committing evil by making mistakes we
expand the imagination of the universe.
Okay which allows the monad to to
expand. Okay. So for in this perspective
sorry so in this perspective
what is happening
is that
each time we imagine we we turn to the
monad.
>> Okay. So, so um it's hard to understand
but the monad it's there it's eternal
but it's it's also becoming it's also
moving and so when we imagine things
when we commit mistakes but at the same
time when we recognize these these
mistakes and um try to adjust for these
mistakes we expand the imagination of
the monad and that's why these secret
societies believe that evil and good
exist together you can only be good if
you do evil
Okay? Because e by committing evil, it
gives you a chance to become better.
Okay? Does that make sense?
>> All right.
All right. So, we're doing Paradise
Lost.
All right.
This is
um the national epic of the British
Empire. If you are a member of the
British Empire, which rules the world
today, the Anglo-American Empire, it
rules the world today. If you are an
elite member of the British uh empire,
you memorize this poem. Okay? And it
becomes part of your soul basically. And
it's it's beautiful. Okay? So this was
written by a man named John Milton. And
John Milton, he was a rebel. He was a
freethinker. He want he questioned the
world. He fought for himself. and he was
a passionate advocate of free speech. He
was a man who wrote Paradise Lost and he
wrote it when he was blind.
He could not see. Therefore, he had to
speak it out and his secretaries had to
write it down for him. And as you can
see,
well, if a blind man is able to recite
poetry, you must think he is a prophet.
He's a messenger of God. What he is
revealing to you is divine truth. Okay.
All right.
So, John Milton
and his most famous work is called
Paradise Lost. And Paradise Lost is the
foundational text of many secret
societies. They read this, they discuss
this, they worship this text. And within
this text lies the secrets of the
universe. Okay? And but only okay this
is this is really uh hard but only if
you understand the secret secrets
yourself can you see the secrets it
embedded in Paradise Lost. Okay.
All right. So what we're going to do is
we will read two speeches by Satan. The
plot of Paradise Lost is really really
simple. It's trying to reimagine
the fall of man. Remember Adam and Eve
are in the Garden of Eden. Then they eat
that fruit and God banishes them. Okay,
so Milton is trying to tell the story
again and he imagines a serpent who
tricks Eve into eating the fruit as
Satan himself. And Satan was God's uh
favorite angel. They had a falling out.
Satan rebelled against God. God won the
war and Satan and the devils are now
banished to hell. And Paradise Lost
begins with the devils discussing what
to do. They've lost this war against
God. They will never ever defeat God.
Now they're stuck in hell. So now what
do they do? Some propose that you know
what? Let's create let's just create an
empire. Okay? Some are like, you know
what? Let's just sit back and enjoy
life. Okay? But Satan is determined to
seek vengeance against God. And so what
he wants to do is go to the Garden of
Eden and corrupt Adam and Eve and
destroy humanity forever.
Okay? So they all agree this is a great
plan. But now the question then is who's
going to go? Because it's dangerous,
right? Because you're escaping hell.
There angels guarding hell. But even if
you leave hell, you go into the abyss.
You go into space, right? You you don't
even know where earth is. You you get
lost for all of eternity. So no one
wants to go. So at this time when no
one's to go, Satan steps up and says, "I
will go." Okay, this is his speech.
Oh progyny of heaven, imperial thrones
with reason have deep silence and demur
ceased us though undismayed. Okay, I
know you guys are scared. All right.
Long as the way and hard that out of
hell leads up to light. Our prison
strong. This huge conduct of fire
outrageous to devour immers us round
ninefold and gates of burning adamant
barred over us prohibit all egress. This
prison is designed to keep us here for
all eternity. It will be hard to escape
this prison.
These paths, if any pass, the void
profound of unessential night receives
him next. Wide gaping of utter loss of
being threatens him plunged in that
abortive gulf. If then he escaped into
whatever world or unknown region, what
remains him less than unknown, in
dangers, and as hard escape. Okay, if
you can leave hell, you're still up in
the abyss of the universe, right? You're
going to be floating there for all
eternity. You don't know where you're
going.
But I should ill become this throne, O
Pierce, and this imperial sovereignty
adorned with splendor, armed with power,
if art proposed, and just of public
moment in the shape of difficulty or
danger could deter me from attempting.
Wherefore do I assume these royalties
and not refuse to reign, refusing to
accept as great a share of hazard as of
honor? Do al like to him who reigns and
so much to him do of hazard more as he
above the rest. Okay, so what he's
saying here is really simple. I'm your
leader and therefore I must go. You have
trusted me to lead you for all eternity
and therefore I will risk my entire life
to prove my worth.
High honor sits. Go therefore mighty
powers, tear of heaven, though fallen,
intend at home, while here shall be our
home. What best may ease the present
misery, and render hell more to toler
more more tolerable. If there be cure or
charm to resppite or deceive or slack
the pain of this ill mansion, interimmit
no watch against a wakeful foe, why I
abroad, through all the crows of dark
destruction, seek deliverance for us
all. this enterprise none shall partake
with me. I am your leader. I will go by
myself. You guys can just sit here and
like sip, you know, have some drinks,
watch some TV, enjoy yourself. I don't
care. Okay? I'm your leader. I will go
by myself to redeem us, to deliver us
from um our torment. Okay? So, as you
can see, this is heroic. He is the grand
hero.
A couple things I will say about the
speech is number one what he's
describing and secretists believe is
believe this is he's describing
his ascent from hell as almost
uh our souls leave our bodies to the
heavens. Okay. And some secret sites
believe that when you die, the first
person you meet is Satan because it is
Satan who knows how to take you from
this world, the prison world to the
light because he's he's done this. Okay.
So, Satan is a very important part of
our journey back to the moon. That's a
also if you study this um poetry very
closely you study the imagery he what
he's describing almost is a baby leaving
the womb right because the baby is a is
in the womb a prison and then the baby
escapes. So secret believe that life and
death are the same thing.
To be born you must die and when you die
you are born again. Okay. All right.
The other thing is that
the secret societies you will use the
speech as an initiation ceremony for
members. When you join secret society
you must by yourself choose to fight for
all of humanity by yourself. You must be
the hero. Okay, you must know when you
join secrets of society, people will
hunt you. People want to kill you for
speaking the truth. Do you do you dare
to go on this journey? Okay, so that's
the first speech. The second speech is
much more important. This is a speech
where Satan, the serpent, convinces Eve
to eat the fruit. Okay? And this speech
is very powerful. Okay? So, I'm going to
read it really fast and then explain to
you what it means. Oh sacred wise and
wisdom-giving plant, mother of science,
now I feel thy power within me clear,
not only to discern things in their
causes, but to trace the ways of highest
agents deem however wise. Eve is talking
to the serpent and Eve is is of course
like hey what can you speak? And the
serpent says because I eat that fruit
from the knowledge of good and evil. It
gives you power. Okay. So the serpent
now wants to convince Eve to eat that
fruit. So he invokes the power of the
tree, right? Oh sacred tree, give me the
power to speak so well that I convince
Eve to do the impossible.
Queen of this universe, do not believe
those rigid threats of death. Ye shall
not die. How should ye? By the fruit it
gives you life of to knowledge. By the
threatener, look on me. Me who have
touched and tasted yet both live. Okay,
so God has warned Eve, Adam and Eve, if
you eat this fruit, you will die. And
the serpent is saying, "No, that's not
true. Look at me. I ate the fruit and
I'm still alive.
And life more perfect have attained than
fate meant me by venturing higher than
my lot. Shall that be shut to man which
the beast is open? Or will God in sense
is higher for such a petty trespass and
not praise rather your dauntless
virtue?" What's in saying here is really
important. If he is a true god, he will
reward you for your risktaking, right?
He said the fruit will kill you as a
test. A true God will want you to become
better and better. And you can only do
that by transgressing, by making
mistakes, by disobeying authority.
And and a true God would reward you for
seeking more knowledge.
Whom the pain of death denounce,
whatever thing death be, deter not from
achieving what might lead to happier
life, not of good and evil. Of good, how
just, of evil. If what is evil be real,
why not known since ease your son shun?
We can only be good people if we know
what evil is. Right? If you don't know
if good and evil, then you're just
stupid.
Okay? It's because you shun away from
evil, you ignore evil, you fight evil,
that you're a good person.
God therefore cannot hurt you and be
just. Not just, not God, nor fear then,
nor obeyed. Your fear itself of death
removes the fear. Why then was this
forbid? Okay, so he's asking himself,
why would God not allow you eat that
fruit? Why, but to all, why to keep you
low and ignorant, his worshippers? He
knows that in the day ye therefore your
eyes that seem so clear, yet are but
dim, shall be then open and cleared, and
you shall be his gods. So what's
interesting is this. There's two
possibilities, okay? Either God is
testing you, God really wants you to
disobey him because that will allow you
to achieve more virtue and knowledge or
God is enslaving you and keeping you
ignorant because God is afraid that you
might become God himself. Okay. So there
are two possibilities.
All right.
What can you not hurt him or this tree
and part against his will of all be his?
Or is it envy? And can envy dwell in
heavenly breast? If he is God, he is in
control of everything. He knows
everything. Therefore, if you eat this
fruit, how could I possibly challenge
him? Unless he's a false god. Unless
he's tricking you, unless he's deceiving
you, unless he's trying to imprison you.
Okay, that's the only possibility. Now
this is sitting speech and you and you
know I took Milton in college. I was an
English major at Yale and I took in a
semester of Paradise Laws and at
university I was taught that this speech
shows you how clever and evil Satan is.
He's lying to Eve. God is invincible
omnisient. You can't eat a fruit and
become God. That's ridiculous. also
either is stupid because he she believes
him, right? That's what you taught in
university. That's what you believe. But
this is really important. When you
actually read the Bible,
Satan is telling the truth.
What what the sin is logic is what the
Bible says. Okay? A professor at Yale
will tell you that sin is lying. When
you actually read the Bible by yourself,
you will see he's telling the truth. So,
we're going to read the Bible together.
Okay, this is what the Bible says. This
is the word of God.
All right, so this is Genesis. Now, the
serpent was more crafty than any other
wild animal that the Lord God had made.
He said to the woman, did God say, "You
shall not eat from any tree in the
garden?" Okay, so in the Bible, this is
actually not Satan. It's just a serpent.
The woman said to the serpent, "We may
not eat of the fruit of the trees in the
garden, but God said, "You shall not eat
of the fruit of the tree that is in the
middle of the garden, nor shall you
touch it, or you shall die." But the
serpent said to the woman, "You will not
die, for God knows that when you eat of
it, your eyes will be open, and you will
be more like God, knowing good and
evil." Okay, so this is exactly what
Satan said. Okay? And this is what the
Bible is saying as well. Now,
let's move on. Eventually, God banishes
Adam and Eve for eating the fruit. And
you believe that they were banished
because they disobeyed God. But if you
actually read the Bible, that's not what
it says. For disobeying God, God
punishes both Adam and Eve. Eve now when
she gives birth will suffer pain, right?
And Adam will now have to work hard to
grow food. That's a punishment. The
banishment is not the punishment. So
another question then is why were they
banished again? Let's read the Bible.
Okay.
So the woman saw
that the tree was good for food and that
was a delight to the eyes and that the
tree was to be desired to make one wise.
She took of its fruit and ate and she
was also gave some to her husband who
was with her and she ate. Then the eyes
of both were opened. Okay. So Satan is
telling the truth. You will not die. You
will learn. You will be become higher.
Okay. Satan was telling the truth. All
right. So what so so what did God kick
Adam and Eve out? The Lord God said,
"See the man has become like one of us,
knowing good and evil, and now he might
reach out his hand and take also from
the tree of life and eat and live
forever." This is why there are two
trees. The tree of knowledge, which
allows you the mind of God, and the tree
of life, which he liv allows you to live
as long as God. What God is saying is
this. If Adam and Eve ate that uh tree
that fruit from the knowledge of good
and evil and then they eat also a fruit
from the tree of life, they will be like
us.
Satan was telling the truth and God was
lying to Adam and Eve all along.
Okay.
So now the question then is
how did Eve know that Satan was telling
the truth? How does she know?
How
>> try? She tried.
>> Well, the problem is if you tried once
and you're wrong, you die, right?
So, how did she know? She was certain
that Satan was telling the truth. She
was certain. Yes, he must be telling the
truth.
Why?
the light in us. You understand? The
true God, the true God still speaks to
us today,
>> right? The false god will lie to us, but
inside you in your heart is the is the
light that connects you back to the
monad. And that tells you what is false,
what is true.
Okay, that's how she knew.
All right, so you see paradise laws is
now showing us the lost secrets of the
universe. All right.
So, um I'll finish with by talking about
the Nephilim.
In the Bible, it says that the Nephilim
are the children of the from angels and
woman. Okay? So, when people began to
multiply on the face of the ground and
daughters were born to them, the sons of
God saw that they were fair and they
took wives for themselves of all that
they chose. And the Lord said, "My
spirit shall not abide in mortals
forever, for they are flesh. Their days
shall be 120 years." Okay. So now God
sees Nephilim as a threat as well.
The Nephilim were on the earth in those
days and also afterward when the sons of
God went into the daughters of humans
who bore children to them. These were
the heroes that were of old, warriors of
renown. Okay, this is really important
because it introduces the Nephilim which
is still around today. Okay, according
to the secret societies, but also what
it's doing is this. It's telling us the
children, the heroes that are of old,
warriors of renown, who are they?
They're Hercules. They're Achilles.
They're Thesius. They're all heroes from
different mythologies. Where do they
come from? They come from the mating of
angels and humans. The sons of God, who
are they? They are the old gods. Zeus,
Aries, Apollo. Okay. So this is the
beginning of monotheism where the Bible
is trying to destroy polytheistic
mythologies and create one universe
where the god is supreme. Okay. And in
this universe Zeus now becomes a son of
god and the children that Zeus has with
mortal woman are now called the nephlem.
So Hercules is Nephilim.
Okay. So we'll go into this theme
throughout the semester where the Bible
is a tremendous act of propaganda that
tries to re reinvent reality around one
true God. Okay? But by doing that it's
denying our intuition and it's denying
the history of humanity. All right.
Okay. So we'll continue this theme next
class. Any questions before we conclude?
Yes.
Well, I think nowadays a lot of us will
pray to God like for getting something
that we wanted. But as you said, like
are we playing like praying to the truth
God or the false god? Do we know or like
do do we get to know like from our
wishes?
>> Yeah. So that's a that's a great
question. So um according to these
secret societies, okay, the truth is
that when you pray, you're praying to
the false god because where's the true
god?
It's inside you. Okay. So don't pray to
an outside force. Look inside to you and
ask yourself, I know for a fact what is
true. If I believe in myself enough,
then I will find the truth. Okay? And
actually that's a theme throughout
Western poetry and literature. The theme
is that we will always be in conflict
with the between the devil and God,
between good and evil. And what we must
do is not say like I must surrender to
God. What we must do is believe in
ourselves. Make mistakes but know that
you will eventually find a light because
the light is in you. Okay? As long as
you still believe in yourself. All this
all these mistakes you make will become
your strength because they become part
of your wisdom. Okay? That's the divine
truth that these secret societies are
trying to promote. It's okay to make
make mistakes. It's okay to do evil.
But listen to the light and the light
will tell you how to redeem yourself.
Okay? The possibility for redemption,
for growth, for imagination is all in us
because of our connection to the monad.
The monad will reward you for believing
in yourself. But you must first believe
in yourself. And believing yourself
means often defying authority, making
mistakes, transgression, transgression
against the rules of society. Okay. And
that's the ultimate secret that these
secret societies are trying to keep. All
right. Any more questions? That was a
really good question. Thank you.
Well,
well, well, the gods
are usually depicted uh the most
beautiful. Then why uh gods like those
they will come to uh human society and
uh give birth um with
um fertilized with the human um girls.
>> Okay.
>> Which is actually not
>> okay. Um so there so the question then
is why are the angels doing this? Okay.
There are two explanations. Okay. So the
first explanation is these angels are
created by the false god, right? So
they're they're wicked anyway. Okay. The
second explanation is that if you're
like a hotl looking woman and you see an
angel,
I don't know, man, you know, you're
probably going to want to marry that
person. Okay. All right. Anyway, um if
you're interested in learning more,
there's a book called the book of Enoch,
which goes into detail about the
Nephilim. Okay. But the nephilim are a
really important topic throughout the
semester because a lot of secret
societies believe in the Nephilim and
that's and that's going to motivate them
before. Okay. Now what I've discussed
today is how these secret societies were
born and as you can see um they started
off as a noble mission but then the
question then is like how do they become
corrupted over time? Well this something
I will discuss later on. Okay. All
right. So I'll see you guys next class.